wie gefährlich ist das feuer das
beantwortet mir jetzt professor
klaus-dieter zastrow herr zastrow
schön dass sie sich die zeit nehmen die
erste frage sie haben die bilder gesehen
aus berlin und von der spd wahlparty
was sagen sie dazu wie schätzen sie das
ganze ein nun das ist natürlich nicht
gut für die situation hier was wir jetzt
gerade sehen in der s-bahn dann tragen
ja sogar noch manche eine maske oder
vielleicht sogar eine ganze menge das
ist also insofern ist das gericht nicht
ganz so dramatisch aber wenn wir jetzt
hier unten sehen wie die beiden damen
sich küssen
na gut da ist dann gegebenenfalls dass
eine von den beiden hat natürlich der
austausch gesichert schlimmer finde ich
eigentlich die situation von dem
spd-parteitag in dem spd treffen dass
wir jetzt hier gerade sehen da muss man
schon mal sagen mein lieber mann das
sind die leute die uns regieren wollen
und die sitzen dann mit 100 mann in
einem saal optisch ein einziger hat eine
maske auf das ist eigentlich schon
handfester skandal dass da die behörden
nicht eingreifen ja also was ist nun
eigentlich zu tun
dann muss man sagen unsere geltenden
regeln die wir in uns schon eine ganze
weile haben
die müssen einfach nur umgesetzt werden
ich weiß gar nicht was man an den regeln
noch verschärfen will man kann nicht
zwei- und mundschutz ansetzen oder sich
eine stunde länger die hände
desinfizieren das alles ist ja nicht
erforderlich aber das was wir wissen und
was wir auch wissen dass es erfolgreich
ist das muss von den behörden umgesetzt
werden
sonst brauchen wir uns über gar nicht zu
wundern zum beispiel in der drei tage
lang ein fest mit 600 leuten läuft dann
frage ich mich wo ist die behörde
gewesen die dieses fest zu ende bringt
bzw eindämmt und natürlich auch
ordnungsstrafen verhängt denn das sind
tatsächlich die hotspots die uns in die
schwierigkeiten bringen wo dann gleich
auf einmal vielleicht mehrere hundert
leute betroffen sind und nicht einzelne
leute und auch nicht zwei drei leute
die aus dem urlaub wiederkommen das sind
diese festlichkeiten die party gefeiert
werden und die kennen ja die behörden
unter brauchen sie das ist leichter
einzugreifen als seien einzelne keine
maske trägt zu erwischen
jetzt hat bundeskanzlerin merkel heute
von einer zahl gesprochen 19.200
neuinfektionen am tag und wie gesagt wir
alle haben uns gewundert woher hat sie
diese zahl wie wahrscheinlich halten sie
dann so was dass sowas überhaupt
eintreffen könnte ja also bei allem
respekt vor unserer kanzlerin aber an
dieser stelle hat sie völlig daneben
wird ich weiß nicht wer ihnen diese
wieder diese zahlen ins ohr geflüstert
hat also die basiert ja auch gar nichts
und das ist ja eine horrorzahl und ich
halte sie auch für völlig unrealistisch
wenn wir unsere maßnahmen einhalten so
über das jetzt eigentlich die letzten
monate vernünftig gemacht haben dann ist
eine derartige zahl fällig weit weg
außerhalb dieser realität keine ahnung
wer das eingetrichtert hat es das jetzt
praktisch das allheilmittel also einfach
nur maß getragen und abstand halten weil
wir können uns ja auch alle nicht
wegsperren bis es irgendwie ein
impfstoff gibt ja unsere bekannten
maßnahmen
das ist natürlich die maske es ist
abstand halten
die händedesinfektion ist in den letzten
wochen und monaten eigentlich nicht mehr
thematisiert worden ist aber natürlich
auch wichtig
ich habe auch schon davon gesprochen
dass man eine desinfizierende
mundspülung durchführen sollte wohl
bemerkt mit einem schleimhaut
desinfektionsmittel nicht mit
irgendeinem und wasser da töten wir
direkt sie viren im bund ab und
reduziert natürlich auch damit die
viruslast in der gesamten bevölkerung
sehr viel mehr bleibt uns nicht oder
besser gesagt ist bleibt uns gar nichts
weiter aber wenn wir das konsequent
machen dann können wir ganz beruhigt die
zukunft schauen
dann wird auch werden wir auch gut über
den winter kommen
wenn wir diese regeln einhalten und die
gastronomen sind ja jetzt auch schon
dabei sich neuere dinge einfallen
das haben wir gestern gesehen diese idee
so dass man also auch weiterhin weit es
gehen soll mal in das restaurant nutzen
kann
aber andere mittel haben wir nicht bei
der hand und und london wollen wir alle
nicht mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren